okay, I had this hat first.
I had the hat first okay.
No one talks I wanna
if I wanna, IF I WANNA WEAR THE HAT,
I can wear the hat.
Does that look good?
Does this look good?
*weird creature noise*
Welcome back
to Trap Adventure 2!
I played it
and um everyone was like
Creepy high pitched fan voice: *Whines* You need to play more
The think though about this game is that its not hard,
I never played a game more easy
then this game.
like even the first level is eas-
*NAILED IT *
like even the first ??
*ZERO DEFFS!!!*
PA PA PA PA PA.....i hate the
stupid ball....OOoooOOOOoo
Enters the opening
PRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRR
go GO go Go
*PRO GAMER*
*GIVING BIRTH*
*its SATAN*
*its over 9000*
*what??*
*PRO GAMER NOISE*
CAMMON MAAAYN !!
*monkey ??*
oh no.....AHHHHHH !!
Come On x10 Go x10
cammon cammon cammon cammon cammon
go go go go go go go go
CAMAAAAAAN !!
*PRO GAMER NOISE*
*ANGER*
(100000% mindpower)
aaayee...look at dat....PRO, I AM PRO MAN??
*Sayori voice* - Hey look I am a submarine !!
ayee..oooo
What?
stop bombing !!
Oh just go down ??
*NAILED IT*
great -_-
ooooh !!
OOOOOoooooooh !!
look......look at dat !!
damit !
*Sayori voice* - Man..he's got good !!
he's got skills !!
*Sane voice* -  Thats' what I've been saying for years !!
for years SON !!
*yeh we know*
camon x 10
camon camon camon MAMAMAMAMA
Where do I do ??
*Satan* - WHAT THE HELL IS DAT ??
DON'T mind doing all that again AT ALL !!
its.......DAGNABIT !!
*Sayori* - hay look it's the ball part !!
*PRO GAMER NOICE*
stupid ball i hate them !! (balls love you)
*Sayori* - cammon Felix you an do it.....
i am your biggest FAAAAN......
i believe in you.....
cammaan Felix......NO !!......
.......cammman Felix <3
*ADULT CONTENT*
**YATHA**
**YATHADISNE**
**KAWAI**
**KAWAI SUGOIDISNEEEE**
(i miss Sayori)
dammaaait !!
look at dis skills maaaan !!
maaan he is guuuud !!
*epic self-motivation*
maaan he is good at this game man !!
holy cow.....
oh..stay here. stay here.
now what ?????????
*ZERO DEFFS MUSIC*
easiest game i have ever played in my life.
go go go go go go go
*NAILED IT*
NOPE -_-
NAANI THE HELL ??
OH stay (its not a dog)
go go gooo
*QUALITY CONTENT*
how the hell i am gonna get in there.....
if i am keep bombing.
(witchcraft)
(fingers crossed)
NOHOOOOOOWWWeh
are you kidding me ??
stay here.
go go go
*PRO GAMER NOISE*
daam am good !!
dam am good and i look good !!
"angaie" i smell good !!
*PRO GAMER NOISE*
YES
NO
wha-the
what do i do ??
stop *crying*
STOP
stop
*STOP*
**STOOOP**
STOOOOOO
*why am i here...just to suffer*
OOOOP...
NO !
one more life please !!
PLEASE
NOOOOoooooo....
*zero deffs*
"sigh"
"done with life"
fine
fffff
seriously !!
*re-booting*
all right !!
easiest game I've ever played in my life !
this game reminds me
of what its like to be a baby !!
because baby's play these GAAAME !!
look....
blindfolded....O_0
*GLITCH IN THE MATRIX*
"laugh"
ok ok ok
NEIGH
you gotta wait man...
you gotta patients. (what??)
patience. (LOL)
shoot it...
all right...its gonna be...
its gonna be a claw !!
and then am gonna have to time it !
boom !!
*struggling*
stop killing me !!
as soon as you drop it go...
go..
*fail*
what...are you stupid or someting ??
ok....as soon as you drop then go....
and then wait.
*waiting*
wait....
noooo...
"excuses in Swedish"
STOP !
*RIP HEADPHONES*
DAMMIT CAN YOU NOT ??
cammon......easy...
this is easy.
*death*
cammon Felix......STOP !!
*surprise Felix*
Noooo....
ARE YOU KIDDING MEEEE !!??
STOOP IT !!
NOOOOOO....
*PRO GAMER*
"MISSION FAILED"
i don't mind replaying it..i think its..####
*shut the f### up*
i dont mind replaying anything cauz its EASY !!
*PRO GAMER NOISE*
there it is...i did it...
i am soo F##### smart ! (christian channel)
*mating call*
HIGH FIVE
"spits"
alright...how do we finish it ??
.how do we finish it ??
*calculating*
pewdiepie.exe ERROR !!
thats impossible !!
gooooo
Damn!!!!
dammit !!
goooveee
WHY DOES HE NOT GOOO?!
*spits all over*
"Bitch slap"
"MISSION FAILED"........(don't give up pewds)
*casting spells*
you got dissss....
you da man !!
you da man, man !!
*PRO GAMER NOISES*
come on, come on, come on!
"heavenly music"
*EPIC FAIL*
*RAGE QUIT ??*
i don't even care......
You're the king of the jungle dude
Are you king?
Damn
King x4 (or 3 or 5 idk)
Easiest game I have ever played
Easiest game i have ever played
Easiest game I have every played  DUDE
Come on Britt Åkerssån?
PÄR KLAS-ÅKER-BRITTSSON!
nice work Brad !! (lol)
*Sayori* - cammon..... first try !!
look at that skill....
that gamer skill.....
(yeh...we are seeing it for 8 mts...2 mts to go)
why do you go down soo muchuu ??
SHHSHSS
STOP
*baby cry*
Stop
last try...
*music intensifies*
*DEATH*
"reset*
(loading...)
*MISSION FAILED*
"again music intensifies"
Come on!
this is game is lot of.....
DAAAAAAAAAMN!
Come on!
death
WHAAAAAAT !!
*PRO GAMER NOISES*
*NAILED IT*
*astonished*
*transforming*
*THE ANTICHRIST REACHES MATURITY*
*HE REALIZES HIS OWN POWER*
*WORLD DOMINATION*
*DESTRUCTION*
leave a like if you enjoyed....this video..
that would really help out a lot !
check out my new merch....
and i will see you guys...
on the.....
NEXT......
*CHRISTIAN CHANNEL*